[Music]
there is chilling new video this morning
linked to the lorry vallo case balo and
her husband chad dabell day bell rather
are accused of killing her children the
bodies of seven-year-old j.j valo and
16-year-old tylie ryan were found on
dave bell's property now this is video
of tyler just about two months before
she disappeared she is talking to the
police about the death of her stepfather
who was shot and killed by her uncle
very complicated story lori balo is
charged in connection with that crime as
well nikki bautis has more
just two months before the killing of
her two children sixteen-year-old tylie
ryan and seven-year-old joshua j.j valo
this is lori valo being interviewed
after the murder of her husband charles
valo in july of 2019. he's always mad at
me right here and he
doesn't want a divorce but i don't like
him and don't i don't know so that's
just how it is
so we married for 14 years we've dealt
with it for 14 years the newly released
evidence about charles vallo's shooting
death includes photos police body cam
video and video of tylee ryan seen
crying before being interviewed by a
detective she describes hearing her
stepfather argue with her mother and the
man police say shot and killed him her
uncle alex cox honestly it feels it
feels like two seconds and
40 minutes at the same time i just kind
of heard
yelling over everything
i don't know i kind of just do that
whenever things are like really loud i
kind of just like tune
what people are saying out video also
shows cox being questioned he died of
natural causes in december of 2019
before any charges were filed against
him lori valo and her new husband chad
dabel have pleaded not guilty to killing
j.j and tyler who were reported missing
in the fall of 2019 their remains found
in daebel's backyard the following
summer the investigation expanded to
include the deaths of chad's first wife
tammy lori's ex-husband charles valo and
her brother alex cox who killed valo
claiming self-defense just tell people
what's happening after his wife's death
chad and lori dabal married and later
moved to hawaii alone the couple is also
accused of profiting from the deaths
court documents revealed chad took out a
large life insurance policy on tammy and
lori continued to collect her children's
social security survivor benefits after
their deaths
i will never keep jj from you lori valo
was later charged in charles vallo's
murder accused of conspiring with cox in
the killing meanwhile chad dabel has
pleaded not guilty and is facing the
death penalty for the murder of the
children lori valo's case is on hold she
remains in custody after being deemed
not competent to stand trial for cbs
mornings i'm nikki batiste in new york